oh are those real yep god-given
the protagonist of the movie is a young
high school boy named Jason who has
gained a good following on the web with
his music while recording a video for
the web he announces to his fans that he
is soon transferring to a new school
Saint adelians a Catholic Academy in
Southern California he then ends the
video by singing a beautiful song in the
next scene we see an unknown lady who
murders someone whoa conceals the body
in a car and addresses as a nun
meanwhile Jason and his sister Zoe
arrive at the new school with their
parents they are welcomed by the
headmistress sister Rebecca who briefs
them about the rules of the school
sister Rebecca also introduces them to
Sarah Zoe's roommate it seems that Sarah
has a crush on Jason due to his charm
and popularity on the web later the
headmistress welcomes a new teacher a
nun from Montana named sister Sophia
white while showing her around the two
nuns bump into Jason at the school
playground surprisingly sister Sophia
finds him handsome and appears to be
interested in him it is also revealed
that she is the same murderous lady from
her real name is Laura but she appears
to have stolen Sophia's identity later
that night the young attractive and
mysterious nun relaxes on her bed
watching one of Jason's music videos
surprisingly she even kisses him on the
screen the ACT seems to be eerily weird
for a nun and it is evident that she is
attracted to the Young musician she
would like to attend to his Mass anytime
the next morning sister Sophia starts
her first day at school once in the
class she sets her eyes on Jason but
gets annoyed and equally jealous when
she sees him and Sarah flirting with
each other so she shifts Sarah to the
first desk much to her annoyance next
Sophia prepares to start her lessons but
right then Zoe reminds her about the
morning prayer they always have before
class hearing this Sophia nervously
instructs the class to start the prayer
but she is unable to recite a single
word herself after class Zoe shares her
suspicion of the new teacher with Jason
but he brushes her off and walks away he
then comes across Sophia and apologizes
for misbeh behaving in class earlier out
of the blue the nun asks if he and Sarah
are together but Jason denies it the
following day though Sophia catches the
two making out enraged she sends Jason
away and starts threatening Sarah that
she will suspend her however the latter
reminds the nun that she has no power
over her since her dad is a donor to the
school Sarah then walks away confidently
leaving the nun infuriated and annoyed
after class Sophia asks Jason to stay
behind which Zoe once again finds really
strange she has been noticing that the
new teacher is pretty interested in her
brother once they are alone Sophia
confronts Jason about the other day
asking why he lied about his
relationship with Sarah Jason
understandably remains mum but Sophia
asks him to meet her in her quarters to
further discuss the matter since
students are not allowed to wander into
teachers quarters Jason is hesitant but
Sophia threatens to report him to the
school board if he doesn't do his asked
therefore the young and unaware lad has
no other choice but to comply later when
Jason arrives at Sofia this Chambers and
is about to knock she shockingly begins
to strip in her lingerie for him he's
scared and confused Jason watches all of
this go down through the cracked door
and soon he feels uncomfortable and
walks away oh man no way or maybe Yahweh
the movie then cuts to the weekend where
the students are getting ready to go
home at the parking lot Sofia is filled
with rage and jealousy as she sees Sarah
and Jason hugging each other the
headmistress interrupts her and talks
about some school work however Sophia
informs her that she will also be away
for the weekend since she has to visit
her sick aunt once back at home Jason
has an intense reunion with his dad it
is revealed that the old man doesn't
support his decision to pursue music he
actually wants his son to become more
like his overachieving sister Zoe after
a heated argument Jason skips dinner and
goes to the pool for some alone time
however unbeknownst to him the obsessed
Sophia has stalked him to his house she
is strangely watching him play guitar by
the pool on Monday night when the
students return to School Sophia sneaks
into Zoe and Sarah's dorm room at the
same time the headmistress Rebecca
notices her and starts following her
next Sophia gets inside the girls room
and plants marry Joanna in Sarah's
textbook hoping to get her out of the
way by suspending her after she is done
with her plans Sophia returns to her
Chambers only to be stopped by the
headmistress on her way back when asked
about why she is roaming the girl's
dormitory so late Sophia lies saying she
was monitoring the Security hearing this
the headmistress walks away but she
still remains suspicious the following
day in class Sophia's evil plan works
when she asks the students to open their
textbooks to a certain page Sarah is
shocked to see the Mary J in her book
which Sophia quickly grabs and reports
to the headmistress as a result poor
Sarah is suspended from school looks
like praying to Mary backfired but the
wicked nun is still not done with her
plans she has the school security check
everyone's dormitory unsurprisingly they
find a bottle of alcohol in Jason's room
the same bottle that Sophia had been
drinking in her car the other night it
turns out that she planted the bottle in
Jason's room so that she can make him
join the community service's punishment
which will give her an excuse to further
seduce him when they find the alcohol
Sophia pretends to sympathize with Jason
and pleads in front of the headmistress
and the school board to not have him
suspended instead she wants him to stay
over the weekend engaged in community
service the headmistress is a bit
skeptical about the idea but after a bit
of thinking she agrees in the next scene
everything works out for Sophia when she
seduces Jason while he is working in the
school garden she unbuttons her shirt
and although the teenager feels
uncomfortable at first he cannot take
his eyes off of her and at night Sophia
finally manages to have coitus in his
own room what's more she even records
the deed on her mobile phone if God's
not watching them Steve Jobs certainly
is the following morning Jason seems to
be understandably worried and guilty so
he leaves the dorm to get some fresh air
meanwhile Zoey at his room looking for
her brother but she becomes surprised
when she catches Sophia sniffing Jason's
clothes when Zoe confronts the obsessed
nun she is told that she will be
reported to the school board for being
in the boy's dormitory Zoe reluctantly
walks out and approaches Jason inquiring
as to what's going on however he doesn't
reveal anything pretending that
everything is fine meanwhile Laura
considers Zoe a threat and devises a
strategy to counteract her after class
she asks Zoe to stay and shows her the
results in which she has failed the
latter cannot believe it because she has
always been a bright student Laura
pretends to care about Zoe and extends a
second chance to her she asks that Zoe
stay after school for the re-exam after
this she purposefully leaves the answer
key on the desk as instructed Zoe
arrives at class to take her re-exam and
notices the answer key on the table as
she looks at it Laura suddenly enters
the classroom and reports her to Sister
Rebecca for cheating however the
headmistress finds it hard to believe as
Zoe always tops her class later a bishop
visits the school and he is welcomed by
the headmistress during their
conversation he inquires if Sister
Sophia is fitting in at the new school
he describes her as a ray of sunshine
which the headmistress finds hard to
believe since the Sophia sheenas is
completely different from what the
bishop has described over the next
weekend Sarah invites Jason to a party
at her house and tells him to bring his
guitar during dinner time Jason asks his
parents if he can attend the party but
the conversation ultimately turns into
an argument about his future regardless
Jason Goes to Sarah's party unaware that
he is being stalked and followed by
Sophia once there Sarah approaches him
and takes him to a room she tries to
kiss him but he is too caught up in his
own mess so he abruptly leaves without
any explanation Jason then grabs a
bottle of beer and leaves the party
while Sarah follows him behind however
she is caught off guard when she
realizes that her car has been
vandalized which is most likely one of
Sophia's Works to get back at her in the
next scene Jason nearly gets into
trouble with the coughs but lucky for
him Sophia arrives just at the right
moment to settle the matter after that
Jason tells her that he is too drunk to
go home in such a condition which
becomes just the perfect opportunity for
Sophia as she takes him to her apartment
she will be doing no fasting abstaining
or confessing tonight once there The
Psychotic nun becomes unreasonably
delusional and asks Jason to leave the
country together but fortunately he
snaps out of his drunken State and flees
from the place the following morning
when Zoe and Jason get ready for school
the former notice is a suspicious car
driving by their house she later finds
out that the car belongs to none other
than Sophia later when Jason returns to
his dormitory he shockingly finds Sophia
unconscious on his bed he also notices a
bottle of pills on the table and
concludes that she committed the
unthinkable terrified he hurriedly
conducts CPR on her hoping to bring her
back to Consciousness and this is when
the paranoid nun suddenly wakes up and
kisses him she then reveals that she was
just faking her death to see if he cared
about her irritated Jason threatens to
report her to the school board but she
instead gets back at him by revealing
that she has a video of them getting it
on with each other this leaves Jason in
a state of utter shock the next day
Sarah returns to school much to Sophia's
anger as she feels threatened she sneaks
into Sarah's room and finds her in the
shower she then bashes Sarah's head into
the wall instantly murdering her but
setting the scene to look like an
accident after a while Zoe finds her
roommate dead in the shower and becomes
horrified the following day she
confronts Jason and asks about his
relationship with Laura at first he
hesitates but when the persistent Zoe
keeps pressing him he finally reveals
everything leaving her stunned Zoe
believes that Laura isn't a real nun as
she behaves differently as a result they
decide to sneak into Laura's room to
look for evidence there they find her
laptop which is filled with pictures of
Jason and also learned that her actual
name is Laura meanwhile the headmistress
learns that Sophia has been lying about
her aunt being sick she angrily
confronts her about it and threatens to
report it to the father of the school
however before she can say any more
Sophia knocks her out with a lamp she
helped her to see the light a while
later the siblings arrive at sister
Rebecca's cabin but are unable to locate
her realizing that something bad
happened to her they rushed to the
church soon Laura also arrives there and
notices Jason holding her laptop she
insists he accompany her but Zoe tells
her to leave him alone this angers Laura
and she immediately knocks Zoe out she
then proceeds to finish off Jason but
Rebecca arrives at the nick of time and
pulls her back enraged The Lunatic woman
strangles Rebecca but Jason takes
advantage of the distraction and stabs
her from behind finally killing her the
final scene of the movie shows the
siblings graduating from high school
despite all that has happened they are
now looking forward to living their life
to the fullest again
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching